fayçal et des gens c'est un plaisir de
vous retrouver pour une vidéo très
spéciale consacrée à amer il paraît
qu'elle est bonne celle ci comme celle
ci j'espère que vous allez bien comme
chaque semaine c'est le moment de se
plonger dans l'ain un jury bon là
comment cette vidéo quoi et sinon je
pourrais aussi vous parler de la
datation à l'uranium plots qui a permis
d'estimer l'âge du plus vieil objet
terrestre connue une roche de zircon
biais de 4,4 milliards d'années mais bon
on va quand même pas commencé à parler
de cailloux sur cette chaîne aime et ce
à cause de mon minérale préférées et oui
vous vous le demandiez ben voilà c'est
dire qu'on oui oui le zircon pas parce
que son nom est une véritable invitation
à la rigolade
donc ça joue pas mal pas non plus parce
que les joailliers l'appel faux diamants
et qu'on en fait des bijoux même si en
ma qualité de femme j'aime tout ce qui
brille non la vraie raison c'est que ce
petit minérale est littéralement le
faire-part de naissance de notre planète
c'est grâce à lui qu'on connaît l'âge de
la terre rhein d'y penser ça me fait une
sorte de l'histoire et bien ça c'est de
la fragilité et ça c'est grâce aux deux
supers pouvoirs de mon petit minérale
fétiche le premier c'est qu'il est quasi
immortel
en fait ils résistent très bien
l'altération un peu comme le quartz est
su qu'on retrouve pléthorique mans dans
le sable une fois que tous les autres
minéraux ont été soit dissous soit
transformé par l'eau est bas le zircon
c'est la même chose en beaucoup plus
balèze c'est le minéral le plus
résistant qu'on connaissait le diamant
est probablement bien classée aussi mais
c'est le zircon le big boss y craint ni
le feu ni l'eau ni l'air ni du code à on
a retrouvé des zircons qu'on plonge et
dans le manteau terrestre au niveau
d'une zone de subduction ils ont été
recrutés après par un volcan est sûre
sorti quasiment intact il avait juste
les arrête
c'est le nokia 34-10 des minéraux c'est
ce qui en fait le plus vieux on a
retrouvé des zircons de plus de 4
milliards d'années sur terre c'était
l'enfance de notre planète et c'est même
la seule trace qu'on est cette période
reculer la plupart des roches de
l'époque ont disparu elles ont été
transformées ou bien enfouie en
profondeur est ce que les roches à la
surface de la terre sont constamment
recyclé merci la tectonique des plaques
mais le zircon lui il se balade de roche
roche comme si c'était une promenade de
santé ce qui fait qu'on trouve parfois
des zircons plus vieux que la roche qui
a autour c'est un peu comme si vous
aviez les yeux de votre grand mère met
littéralement elle est vraiment salée je
me ferais jamais ça change des brèches
les amis par un truc très bizarre alors
du type qui chie dans un seau petits
gourmands après tout les ir qui n'ont
pas forcément un âge incommensurable
puisqu'il continue de s'en forme et
encore aujourd'hui sous nos pieds au
coeur des chambres magmatiques
simplement une fois créés ils ont une
durée de vie plus longue que lady di et
c'est tant mieux parce que comme ils
sont résistants l'altération il concerne
la mémoire de ce qu'ils ont vécu
et en plus ils peuvent nous raconter
leur histoire grâce à leur second super
pouvoirs ils sont radioactifs zoom un
cristal de zircon c2i reconnaît mais du
silicate qui font de la crau j'ai
parfois un atomes d'uranium cas
radioactifs car jack le cristal et
s'installe à la place du zirconium toute
impunité
attendez là j'ai dit le mot qui fait
peur femmes non pardon l'autre
radioactifs
oui le zircon est radioactif mais à des
doses tellement faible qu'il est
inoffensif pour nous si on apporte en
bijoux par exemple donc relax il ya
moins d'uranium dans votre pendentif qui
a des lecteurs du rassemblement national
dans votre famille elle est toujours
aussi sale épices ou
donc revenons à notre cirque on à
l'intérieur l'uranium mais pas à l'aise
dans son corps il sent boudine il a
qu'une envie c'est de perdre du poids
avant l'été diktat des magazines
féminins
on dit qu'il est instable alors vous
vous le faire un régime il émet des
particules et de l'énergie et il devient
un autre élément du plomb qui lui est
stable voilà en vrai c'est pas un petit
régime mignon qui fait l'uranium 1 c'est
carrément un extreme makeover mais on va
faire simple mais après la théorie la
pratique fumer un joint avec un petit
plateau en argent et 1 vert 1 champagne
propre en cristal de bohême ceux de deux
autres regardez regardez ce que
l'uranium fait aux ir qu'on vous voyez
cette auréole noir tout autour de lui le
camp l'uranium se désintègre les
particules qui l'aimaient vous percutez
ses voisins et les envoyer valser
bonsoir au lieu d'être bien rangé les à
tourner aux alentours vous baigner
maintenant dans un joyeux chaos
vous aurez peut-être compris où je veux
en venir c'est toriola cdu verts on
appelle ce phénomène la méthanisation je
trouve ça un peu facilement on peut
admirer les faits de la radioactivité
sur un minéral j'ai pas c'est fou non
écoutez moi bien on est à peu près tous
d'accord tu demandes plus ou moins
n'importe qui il te dira on s'en fou à
force de déplacer les attentes comme ça
vous vous en douterez ça abîme le
minéral ça fragilise sa structure du
coup il sera plus vulnérable et quelque
part je trouve ça beau se dire que le
zircon ne craint aucun élément extérieur
son seul ennemi est en lui
voici un des lieux les plus froids de la
planète
[Musique]
et voici mon cul pour les géologues
qu'un général soient radioactifs c'est
une manne ou plutôt une mine est-ce que
ça permet de connaître son âge plus un
minéral et vieux - et contiendra
d'uranium et plus contiendra de plomb et
du coup on peut même calculer son âge
en regardant la proportion d'uranium et
de plomb qui a dedans mais il ya tous
les éléments radioactifs ne se valent
pas reprenez le carbone 14 un autre
radio éléments qu'on utilise aussi pour
dater des machins il a une demi vie de
près de 6000 ans ça veut dire que si
j'en prends une poignée il faudra
attendre 6 mai ans pour que la moitié ce
soit d intégrer et en général on estime
que toute la poignée se serait
désintégré après midi vie donc pour le
carbone 14 c'est à peu près dans
cinquante soixante mille donc pas s'en
servir pour bat et des restes organiques
récents comme des fossiles humains ça
c'est cool mais si vous voulez
l'utiliser pour dater des dinosaures ont
disparu il ya 65 millions d'années tout
ce qui pourra vous dire c'est qu'il a
plus du tout carbone 14 dedans donc que
votre dinosaure à plus de 50 milles ans
ce nous fait une belle jambe
et c'est pour ça que en géo chronologie
on utilise d'autres éléments à demi vie
plus longue comme les couples potassium
argon rubidium strontium et notre fameux
uranium plomb puisque l'uranium a une
demi vie respectable de 4,47 milliards
d'années ça veut dire qu'il nous
permettrait de dater des minéraux
qu'aurait 36 milliards d'années donc
plus vieux que l'univers lui-même pour
savoir d'où on a de la marge
notre cirque ont il est présent sous
forme de traces dans plein de roche à la
surface de la terre et ça c'est hyper
cool ça veut dire qu'on peut dater plein
de trucs donc on prélève les très rares
minéraux dire condensé cailloux et on
les dates grâce au très rare atomes
d'uranium qu'ils contiennent et l'âge
qu'on arrive à connaître ses suites la
cristallisation de notre zircon nancy
cela sa naissance les amis je suis
choqué la banane est un fruit merveille
sa structure n'ont aucun sens comme pas
mal de trucs que je vais vous présenter
dans cet épisode là ça tournait
l'innocence la pudeur ou la chasteté
bon alors évidemment là ce truc de
datation ça ne marche plus et zircon et
replonger dans un magma là il perd toute
sa mémoire comme fait ou dit que son
horloge est réinitialisé
parce qu'en fait
parce qu'en fait comme une aile chauffer
tout pour qu'il contient pas s'échapper
et donc c'est comme s'ils venaient de se
former un truc que je trouve incroyable
par contre c'est que saisir qu'on est
juste partiellement chauffer et
bellegarde sa mémoire il ne perd qu'une
partie de son plomb et du coup il peut
nous raconter quand il s'est formé et
quand il a été réchauffé sa chance à
super fort quand même
quelle est la différence entre l'ama
fâché et quelques gardes
j'ai une réponse concrète à vous donner
à cette question que le cul déjà j'ai
toujours été un peu fan des dinosaures
et pluvieux zircon pas du tout cette
titre je tue comme ce pitre
comment les plus vieux toujours pas à
l'heure actuelle les plus vieux minéraux
qu on ait trouvé sur terre ses désirs
compte de 4 4 milliards d'années on en
parlait tout à l'heure ils ont été
retrouvés dans des grès métamorphisées
en australie ils sont forts mais juste
son petit million d'années après la
naissance de la lune par la terre ses
fins plafonné par un bébé planètes de la
taille de mars
le choc a été tellement violent que ça
fait fondre les roches sur terre et ça a
créé un océan de magma à partir duquel
ont pu cristalliser nos dire qu'on vous
rendez compte
ça veut dire que nos cirques ont
pratiquement vu naître la lune et ce qui
est marrant c'est que vous êtes encore
là c'est marrant et j'ai toujours pas
parler de l'âge de la terre et barney
vient justement
étrangement c'est pas grâce à des roches
terrestres qu'on l'a trouvé c'est grâce
à des météorites
parce que ces corps là n'ont pas été
remaniée constamment comme a pu l'être
la terre du coup ils ont conservé leur
mémoire et pour vous présenter cette
découverte
laissez-moi vous introduire claire a
battu son club additionnel un
géochimiste amérique dans les années 50
il date des zircons prélevés dans la
météorite canyon diablo aux etats unis
ils les analysent grâce à une variante
de la méthode uranium plomb qui met au
point lui-même
il s'appelle la méthode peuple errant
que son nom qui est rigolo du coup je
vous passe
en tout cas c'est comme ça qui va
déterminer cette fameuse date de
naissance de la terre celle qui a encore
admis aujourd'hui 4,54 milliards
d'années à trois poils de sion presse
la terre s'est pas formé comme ça en un
claquement de doigts ni en un clin
d'oeil entre la poire et le fromage ça a
quand même pris au moins plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'années ce
résultat il a peut être confirmée de
plusieurs manières en battant les mêmes
qu'un lieu avec d'autres éléments
radioactifs potassium argon et remise
abstentions dont on parlait tout à
l'heure et en date en plein d'autres
météorites depuis et tout ça concorde
ainsi donc tout porte à croire que la
terre serait bel et bien né il ya quatre
milliards et demi d'années avant josiane
balasko
mais là vous vous dites que je débloque
complètement parce que là en fait on a
adapté une météorite on n'a pas du tout
date et la terre et ben en fait a priori
c'est la même chose on pense que les
corps rocheux du système solaire serait
née de l'effondrement sur lui-même d'un
disque de poussière comme un frisbee
cosmi autour du bébé soleil et du coup
comme ça s'est fait en même temps tout
ce joyeux monde aurait le même âge on ne
dira jamais assez mais ne regardez
jamais jean marie bigard d'un érudit un
poil sous l'eau est comme un peu dans
l'espace un peu comme lorsqu'on va
changer ma grand-mère une expérience qui
a seulement salma déraper le caca c'est
merveilleux ça se mange sans faim parce
que ça fait pas une belle chaîne
alimentaire tout ça donc en fait ça fait
une septantaine d'années qu'on connaît
la date de naissance de notre point bleu
pâle chanson un peu fou que ce soit si
récent chez moi comme mes grands parents
étaient jeunes et peut-être les vôtres
aussi oui ça fait bizarre on croyait
encore que la terre avait une centaine
de millions d'années tout au plus son
temps dit comme ça on a l'impression que
c'est une question tu peux fondamentale
enfin je sais pas quel est l'âge du
grand vaisseau cosmique qui nous
transporte dans le vide spatial pourquoi
sommes nous là qu'y at il après la mort
quelle sauce va mettre dans mon cas
qu'on est bas que nenni sauce blanche
c'est ce que cette question personne
n'avait rien at-elle quai pendant des
siècles et particulièrement les
géologues
alors certes c'est des religieux qui
avaient toutes des trucs en étudiant la
bible l'archevêque irlandais rusher a
estimé la date de création au 23 octobre
4004 avant jésus-christ selon certaines
versions à 9 heures du matin heure
mésopotamienne du coup la terre est
scorpion si vous vous demandiez d'autres
pensaient que la terre avait peut-être
toujours été là comme le géologue thomas
sutton dans sa théorie de la terre au
19e il écrit oui fin
vestige on va dégainer ne respecte rien
contrôler une foule
[ __ ] merde on ne trouve nulle vestiges
d'un début nulle perspective d'une fin
[Musique]
ils sont
jusqu'à ce que le physicien super stars
de l'époque des barques tel un éléphant
dans un magasin de porcelaine j'ai nommé
william thompson alias lanthiez ville il
s'est dit que ce mystère ne resterait
pas un savant calcul pour lui la terre
est à l'origine une boule de magma qui
se refroidit très lentement spoiler il
avait raison et grâce à la visite de
pointe de son épée
il a calculé le temps qu'il faudra à la
terre pour refroidir jusqu'à atteindre
en surface sa température actuelle et il
est tombé sur 20 à 400 millions d'années
à la douce qui la réduit après en 20 à
40 millions d'années ces travaux ont
quelque peu chafouine et les géologues
de l'époque parce qu'il n'aimait pas
qu'un physicien avec ses grandes
hypothèses en l'air la vienne marcher
sur leurs plates bandes
c'est vrai quoi laisser nous ramasser
des fossiles en paix et colorié nocar
biologique il y en a un autre qui était
par aviez non plus son nom châu son
prénom
darwin pour lui l'évolution avait au
moins besoin de plusieurs centaines de
millions d'années pour que et pourtant
le résultat de kelvin restera la
référence pendant près d'un siècle
en même temps je sais pas il à la
pilosité d'un mec qui s'y connaît il a
utilisé des équations et tout ça à
parader puisque est rigolo c'est que
d'autres expériences complètement
indépendante donner des résultats à peu
près approchons comme l'anglais john
jolly qui a estimé le temps qu'il
faudrait pour que les océans deviennent
aussi salek une tradition chez starbucks
grâce aux sels minéraux que les rivières
arrache au continent zoom dézoom zoom
dézoom et bien ça c'est vraiment pas le
viol et moi c'est ma couleur préférée
donc toutes ces expériences concordaient
vers une centaine de millions d'années
le consensus de l'époque un résultat
qu'on sait faut aujourd'hui mais le pire
c'est que dans les faits kelvin avez
raison il était juste passer à côté deux
éléments importants d'abord les
mouvements de convection à l'intérieur
de la planète ce qu'on connaissait pas
du tout à l'époque à l'échelle de la
planète en fait les roches du manteau se
déplace elle se comporte comme si elle
était liquide du coup et bah ça va
redistribuer la chaleur à l'intérieur de
la pièce dit ça on en reparlera dans une
autre vidéo dans de petits chanceux et
deuxièmement la radioactivité une source
d'énergie qui provient des roches et qui
produit de la chaleur mais ça c'est pas
de sa faute non plus on l'a dépeint plus
tard au début du xxème donc à cause de
ces deux facteurs la terre se refroidit
plus lentement que ce qu'avait prévu ce
sale physiciens qui se prenait pour un
géologue par contre les géologues eux
ils étaient hyper content de pouvoir
enfin dire à kelvin qu'ils avaient tort
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'ils se
sont saisis de ce nouvel outil un outil
qu'on appelle sobrement m'habite très
problématique ce nouvel outil quitter la
radioactivité pour se dire mais ça fait
comme une horloge en fait peut-être
qu'on va pouvoir dater genre des
cailloux avec non ils en avaient
vraiment à rien assis
il était même plutôt méfiants vis-à-vis
de cette sorcellerie et du coup c'est
les physiciens et des chimistes qu'ils
en sont emparés qui s'en sont emparés et
c'est pour ça que les première datation
de roche c'est des chimistes qui les
envahit publier des bons résultats dans
des très bonnes revues qui passaient
complètement à l'as du coup c'est
chimiste avait un petit peu les boules
les uns après les autres ils sont 10es
bas puisque tout le monde s'en fout je
change de sujet de recherche
et puis allez vous faire cuire des
knacki il a fallu attendre les années
1910 pour qu'un premier géologue
s'empare de cet outil c'est l anglais
arthur il était tellement à fond qui
l'adapté sa première roche quand il
était encore étudiant en licence
il a passé sa vie à faire du lobbying
pour montrer à quel point la géo
chronologie c'est trop bien est ce
robuste à 23 ans 4 ans avant d'avoir sa
thèse il a même publié un bouquin qui
s'appelle l'âge de la terre et du coup
il estime l'âge de la terre donc au fil
de ses recherches entre 1,6 et trois
milliards d'années donc c'est plutôt pas
mal
on s'en approche et figurez-vous que
contre toute attente il a fini par faire
bouger les choses
en 1929 la communauté scientifique
consent enfin à modifier l'âge de la
terre de 100 millions à plusieurs
milliards d'années ils admettent aussi
que oui ok la radio datation se pacifier
et puis dans les années 50 paterson
reprend le flambeau mais vous connaissez
la suite
aujourd'hui ces méthodes sont
complètement entré dans la routine du
géologue en a quand même parcours un
gros bout de chemin en un siècle et
quelques à mon avis c'est pas fini
puisque on commence tout juste à jouer
avec des nouveaux radioéléments ou qu'il
ait pas dit que l'âge de la terre qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui reste absolument
figé il peut très bien tu es encore un
peu dans tous les cas arthur holmes
pourrait être fiers de nous mais
probablement qu'il s'en câlisse parce
que chacun son tour
on
mettons que vous ayez une relation un
peu spéciale avec votre cheval
à force de sensuel caresses et ses non
dits et que ses fils caire rien ne me
plairait - rassurez vous je peux
comprendre c'est tout à fait
envisageable
moi ça me ferait plaisir si vous
apportez quelque chose que grand bien
vous fasse cet épisode est délicieux
pour finir voilà j'attends un heureux
événement votre d'onde sur youtube
l'outil merci infiniment hotspur qui me
supportent la simple idée de savoir que
vous existez c'est complètement
incroyable
merci à david merci à ma maman merci aux
ir con merci la vie
si vraiment c'était une séance de
comptoir sur ce
[Musique]
ça vous a plu vous envoler encore et
bien retrouvez moi sur la chaîne youtube
du vortex où on vient de lancer la
troisième saison et c'est moi qu'il
inaugure avec une vidéo sur les origines
évolutive du rire donc aux gros pourquoi
on rigole est-ce que yad autres animaux
qui rigole ce genre de truc tout caler
sur la chaîne youtube du vortex et puis
sinon j'ai lancé ma chaîne twitch aussi
donc on va commencer à faire quelques
petits live intéressant notamment des
lives à smr avec des guest que je vous
laisse découvrir twitch pointé vers la
science de comptoir et puis si vous
voulez pour l'occasion peut se faire un
petit live à la sortie de cette vidéo
comme ça on pourra débriefer ensemble
venez on va rigoler ça va être cool
[Musique]